and the couples you've worked with is
there
like the feminine and the masculine is
there different dynamics that come into
play like dominant submissive is there
is it like a dance where it just changes
from minute to minute is there is there
dynamics that you observe that both
limit and enable
uh successful relationships yes so there
are if we're talking about masculine
feminine
then how also we could get into are we
talking about actual gender identified
gender or are we just talking about
these traits because like I said I
Stonewall which is typically in couples
something that is more associated with
straight men
um
but that's my style of coping when I get
overwhelmed uh that is not tied to any
sort of success or non-success of a
relationship but what we do know is that
gay couples so lesbians and gay men tend
to be gentler with one another when they
are having conflict discussions I so
that's actually been identified in the
research and it's something I've
witnessed and it's just fascinating so
with my Straight couples I'll be going
through one of these if we're processing
a conflict that occurred I'll be going
through the sheet and it's very very
structured because you don't want
couples doing more damage when they're
there with you you want them practicing
skills that protect them from criticism
that protect them from contempt
and when I'm working with a straight
couple I am like a referee or sometimes
I'll relate it to being like a ski coach
and keeping people on a bunny Hill and
you tell them you let them make like two
turns and then you stop them and you
meet up again because you don't want
them to Veer off with straight couples
you are doing very short turns before
you need to kind of intervene and
rescaffold
I had a lesbian couple recently and they
were so lovely with each other they
skipped like seven steps to the advanced
final portion where they were already
coming up with Solutions and suggesting
things that they might be able to do
differently next time to make it better
for their partner they were asking each
other questions about how their partner
felt with no agenda no attempt to sort
of be like well do you think you're
feeling that way because which straight
couples do all the time you just see
this humility and openness it's lovely
yeah it's lovely but I wonder if uh
maybe watching too many Hollywood films
is some of the drama some of the tension
is required for a passionate lifelong
romance no it's not and that's great
news
so we actually know yes that The Closer
You Feel to your partner so if I mean
you've talked a lot about beauty and
you can ignite that beauty that interest
right so when you're falling in love
it's usually that a person is sort of a
mystery to you and you're uncovering
these layers that you find really
appealing
there are continual layers that you can
uncover with your partner over time I
don't think we realize that I think we
get complacent and we think we've had
every conversation imaginable what what
else are they going to do to surprise me
but we don't know the questions to be
asking
one of my favorite questions
um
I like turning these conversations kind
of into a quiz because I get bored
easily so you rather than just asking an
open-ended question
um there's a way you can do this with
your partner where it's sort of like the
dating game like what is my as of yet
fondest but unrealized life dream and
see if your partner knows you might not
even know they might know you better
than you know yourself that in and of
itself is a beautiful reminder of the
relationship and how special it is
but then also
um
when they say it or when you realize or
have to think critically like what is my
husband's as of yet unrealized but
fondest life dream and then you can talk
about it
you just I don't know you just kind of
transcend into this new area and you
feel tight again you feel like you feel
close well you really
talk to each other like I I've recorded
and without
intending to publish uh podcasts like
this with microphones with with friends
with people close to me because it's
literally that you get to ask questions
like as if it's an interview right and
we don't do that exactly it the way
you're talking with me yeah sit down
with your partner have that conversation
like years later right show interest
actually be curious see see what they
surprise you with and actually when you
learn is you don't know the answers to
most of these questions 100
exactly like like what what's your
favorite movie from the 80s you might
not know the answer to that it's like
those first date questions or whatever
or what's your favorite movie this year
and why and why yeah it's fascinating it
is it's hard to do that because I think
that you'll probably be offended at
first how little the other person knows
so I think you have to work through that
you know I actually find that there's
this rekindling because partners are
shocked that their partner does know so
much about out them especially if
they've been feeling dissatisfied or
disconnected it's a reminder of all the
good that's still there